come down it's a pretty cool horror game
if you missed out on this series click
here and watch the first episode and
catch up I am how you doing handsome
this guy was a nice poster oh there we
go
what are you doing Cher I don't [ __ ]
trust you I feel like they're real ok no
whoa that is creepy
all right anyway that's a kiss mwah all
right what is that no way Samuel Cabot
how do you know that from there girl
that's creepy lip syncs oh I would not
give that lady Pb Pb my name is Pierre D
ontology ah sweet chat with shouting now
just could that boat [ __ ] about
alright I guess what's the objective
here sorry for clothes alright so now we
got to find oh hold on hey please oh how
that hurts
whoa boot whoa hey hit nap [ __ ] you for
hitting lamb that's what you [ __ ]
shut up you don't hit lamp
sorry about that lamp okay I need fire
axe here probably
again alright I don't need those right
now I hope I remember to edit in the
right corner I always forget it it's
like lunch lady
what shall shall I say lunch lady whoa
Oh lunch lady sent you what smack ow ow
I don't bite me right to them dick pick
up chip all right I thought I saw some
better weapons over here no I guess I
grabbed one of these and then do it
quick say good time Bob that day go down
boy all right [ __ ] grab aah I stopped
today I swear to god I love a day Jim
prepare I miss you man
all right let's get the lunch lady
payday [ __ ] yeah we'll get the lunch
lady crying through that shotty sorry
prepare you always go how did that not
hit you with all right whoa
damn that got a bad ass how do i I have
three bullets left all right
whoa how do you shoot me through the
[ __ ] wall ah come on don't shoot
don't shoot reducing over shell shell
sorry Jesus
sorry about that all right I got the
submachine [ __ ] I feel bad that's right
now come on bring it
I think I'm a boost think I'm afraid
afraid is afraid is my middle name kind
of trip
whoa blaze it's pretty epic
hey don't have to sneak up on me there
we go
[ __ ] retime guys snicker exit thank
you
I guess now we got to go to the school
[ __ ] I don't want to go to the school
man I don't want to go in the darn stuff
what what are you doing that's not how
you walk down stairs
hey Hagrid oh you didn't Brown hooked
stupid [ __ ]
all right oh thanks go ah I need
deodorant nice alson who did that rats
don't touch lamps that's thing I need to
learn about oh there's nothing how we
doing in here ah [ __ ] me we gotta fight
your lunch lady first all right lunch
lady I love your food very healthy I
hope this is working like I'm touching
your [ __ ] lunch lady
you're not pass
lunch lady our lunch lady knew its name
whoa what are you alive of course you
are
that's anymore though actually maybe not
all right here we go
if you like it and you're sure to put a
boot on it if you don't like it like
that in a final battle begins [ __ ]
shock your titties
Oh Katie if I have to I don't [ __ ]
trust this [ __ ] you lady
if you don't like it then you should put
it
oh come on Panda you can do better than
this
oh I you better be oh not cool bro meat
cleaver required a [ __ ] you I'm guessing
that [ __ ] I'm getting that
Roxy there's a lot of [ __ ] damage I
am [ __ ] screwed oh [ __ ] me [ __ ] me
alright conduit [ __ ] [ __ ] Chuck your
titties girl Oh what you got to do about
it so I [ __ ] broke that [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] that is bull what the
hell am I supposed to kill dad what the
hell
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] I tell you he
can
[ __ ] again whoa another one [ __ ] are
you okay bro if you don't like sure to
put a boot on it
if you don't like it they be sure to put
a boot on it they're just shut up yo yo
shut up you're so lame
so lame if you like it then you should
break up ow yeah that's all I got shut
up now Ashley
[ __ ] me I actually please done all right
wait oh she's so fat ah [ __ ] hate you
I can hate you back all right quick sake
don't die don't die don't agony if you
don't like it then shoot a pickup to
power I'm seriously trying yeah I'm not
like playing if you come on lunch lady
what what the Heather the bucket ever do
to you
alright I think we got a target going
here oh you ain't got no range [ __ ] we
got no range come here girl oh you been
you pitch cut you fat up and a lunch
lady I know it's a [ __ ] that's right
the boob punch and give me that cleaver
Aaron it now I will do something
disgusting fact that was gross all right
the ironies you're coming with me
brother
[ __ ] you come on it she's dead
you're free man Oh what the [ __ ] oh god
I don't like you I put you if you don't
like thank you [ __ ] step [ __ ] oh that
[ __ ] game for man all right where the
[ __ ] were we if you don't like a Danish
sure to put a boot on it
beyond sin no it was right I tell you as
much I tell you it's much burger mmm
sure to put it see I don't even lose
health man I'm too MLG at this [ __ ]
alright here we go oh [ __ ] you come on
man you run like come on man are you
dead are you okay stay down [ __ ] this
hand going through his penis [ __ ] is
wrong with these people
they're bad that's right anyone want to
tango I don't dance tango my like [ __ ]
it's gonna come from the window I think
oh what the [ __ ] Oh shadow where is it
[ __ ] creepy alright whoa
alright let's go out of court what
Shella bro do tell
huh what the hell did I just do
whoa is that an arm of course I should
have known
let's do some Seuss um it's not a
football
all right let's investigate they are my
guess probably
oh it's clean are there all right i'll
ladies fingers all right what do you got
well he's [ __ ] fast man
go or a girl I don't know what cheers to
be on it all right
I don't like that
no I don't
Oh oh [ __ ] well I love jump jump
temperatures in June of course [ __ ]
down here too if you don't like it then
you should a Buddha I don't like this
looking right through a cry here alright
we'll go here then [ __ ] now I got to be
on there my brain oh thank god I need
actually I don't need it of course
[ __ ] everywhere glad you're with me
deodorant glad you're with me
alright I will actually end this episode
here like a baby be enjoyed subscribe to
go home bro today and I'll see you next
episode over ironic stay awesome bros
[ __ ] or I will [ __ ] you up
alright will you - let me take a piss
you hear me
do you hear me now what Kennedy